excusing to is an expansion from
seedless he's the one who built this
world and we sort of showed you a little
bit of what this school looks like and
it's following Brian this repetition of
water and has desert acclimates to this
crazy new environment and now we get to
show other schools and inter-school
competition and what does you know the
dorm life look like and what does being
a professional clinical professional
gamer in a school setting and how does
he you know balance these two things and
also we're gonna change the length of
the episode so instead of doing web
series ranked like six to ten minute
episodes we found that everybody loved
the twenty two minute long last episode
of season one so now we're all right
wait a six TV like 20 to 25-minute
episodes yeah cuz the frozen ones
essentially like confines big pilot like
every big movie in as a classic movie
structure is very like a tease sports
movie you follow this one kid and Brian
the main character of the movie because
it's a movie Strider you don't really
see much really but talent one hand a
little bit like yeah it's not very many
and for this one it's like well we know
we wanted to do a sequel but we don't
want to do a movie sequel like well is
it gonna be Brian Frank's another bully
like it's not gonna happen and everybody
loved the side characters and we loved
key and we said and we loved Jenny looks
like we won't give these people all
these stories so we went to TV structure
and now we've you know we've introduced
this world and now we can apply it so we
can do six completely separate stories
that are still had like an orchid the
law has a big arc throughout the season
and the biggest are because honestly
like Jenny and her mom is this big
mother-daughter story and then Brian's
and then they have Ted has a story and
everybody has their own stories but all
the episodes every little story so again
it's it's gonna be gonna be like things
six big episodes of TV Carly having meal
time
back again as headmaster and you she
loved the scenery solo first season that
he has a whole whole bunch more yeah
this time around
Jenny's Mohammed is played by Cynthia
watt Rose who has a TV actually she
there's a lost John eNOS as keys dad you
might know Jodi Ackley he was comedy
fashion home from mister show and big
and prompt I've been around forever he's
been in like I'm really if you look I
was on TV so I like everything we do
have a couple cameos that we're not
gonna say anything about yet but we're
very excited yeah
a huge ego try to try to save away
towards the character me not it's
powerful would seep into just a little
bit
what was on there we go we were 2009 we
were kicking around ideas I was working
on a Direct TV feature film at that time
and one of our friends got in crisp a
professor things I should producer this
season just kidding around that menu
throughout video game high school
announces house it and then we went with
it and that will kick in ideas around
we've been working on this as a concept
for a while since that time just always
kept coming up it was a really we should
we should come back and yeah yeah that
different show idea to kind of office
style shows right that wanted were
trying to grab them for the first one
can they deal with the company so we're
like we should use a more
action-oriented doesn't mean I start
talking about video game high school
when we came up her stuff and he brought
in the other writers gotta develop it a
bit that's right and so that was
basically it's been the ideas been
kicking around since even before the
YouTube channel has been around
we generally split it so this season we
are going to do some in-house and we're
going to be
YouTube creators to essentially be it's
like a it's like a crash-course
professions we have a lot of effects
that can be done just in after-effects
and I can teach people how to do us
about something that we're working with
the creators that are in that first
class here at the YouTube space on and
then the more complex stuff we're
working with the same company that we
didn't season one that we call play
fighters based on Canada who we met a
year and a half ago I want to call do
the offense in LA and we had been fans
of their work as they had done a couple
call duty shorts by makarov and
operation swordfish shorts and they were
familiar with us and we kept in touch
and now they're the effect company that
does the hard the effects for I mean
with every method of funding
there's upsides and downsides right so
if you build a traditional method and
you're getting an investor to come in
the downside is now you have to pay that
investor back and oftentimes in general
industry chatter of 10 to 50 20% return
on that that's how like direct-to-dvd
future fails but that's really where we
were previously with this the downside
is you have to deliver because he built
up all this hype to it and you also need
to deliver actionable items that he's
gonna be doing tdz maybe do the posters
and doing all the stuff that you've
promised in the kitchen reward thing you
have to deal with the whole level of
business they don't normally I made it
with manufacturing right shifting all
our stuff now then go making now
filmmakers but now we're sitting there
being like we need to find teacher
manufacturer who can we get to do this
who can your own PR and we ship it so
it's it's a give-and-take what's been
why we really like crowdsource funding
is for us that sort of side of it
delivering DVDs and digital downloads
and all those sort of rewards is lost
fun and it's actually not really it for
us it's just being able to interact
and we have no problem doing it you know
and it gives us a lot of freedom and
what we're doing because a lot of times
again once you're taking money from
outside sources they have a lot saying
what they're doing but what's nice about
the Kickstarter and the crowdsource
model is we got the cash to make the
project the way we want to make it and
we don't have someone you know some
producer hasn't as an overseer be like
trying to dictate the creative the city
so we have that creature look it's not
really a downside but I feel like
there's some similarities so I can deal
with like if you're like doing a Marvel
movie or something it to deal with the
fans and it's instead of being holed
into a producer you now kind of have
people that have already given you money
and while there's not like a
quote-unquote investment stake in it
there is like a sense of like I know
people have already paid for this
project and then put if I have enough
pressure but it just definitely puts
it's a different relationship I think
downside that's nothing different you
feel a bigger complication yeah rather
than just like help do this and then
throw it out maybe two more like it
you're like people have already said
they like it yeah I better deliver on my
expectations to be fully transparent
we're not like completely we're not
completely profitable yeah this is
anyway here's the thing though because
we're not looking at this as a single
season situation we've always looked at
Beauty just as a three season mark and
what we're doing here is something that
is difficult and something that I don't
think has quite been done in this way in
the web video space so the first step
was art let's put it out there let's get
the name out there let's let's build it
up right so we expect to take a bit of a
loss on that
and then season 2 season 3 is when a
follow-up is after it's been built up so
we'll see how this experiment works
Apple yeah we'll talk about that after
we hit season here because we have yet
we have still you know we still have
merchandise myself do business after
season 1 season 2 has a whole slew of
stuff that we wanna do for an season 3
as well so in that thing you know it's
like as at this moment what we want to
do is we want to look at the whole
project as a three season arc and see
where that goes and see how the sort of
financial model because we're not
starting with you know Halo or Mortal
Kombat we had to essentially crave with
a person was essentially create our own
IP first exactly how that cost money
that took time and it you know it's a
sort of thing I know we've essentially
developed this IP and just like studios
- yeah it's not that uncommon and now
hopefully the seasons two and three
we'll see how the model works and if not
then we figure out some girls oh you
know it's funny because I think it could
exist and sort of like that short form
but we're actually more excited about
all the other weird ways that can exist
I so we did like a comic book and then
for the first season as a joke almost
the last-minute thing you guys are
sitting around yeah we have this crazy
idea for kagra and we throw it in as a
free as a freebie for the Kickstarter
DVDs and it was a lot of fun and then
we're like even with them we've all
within time like man this is like an
anime like an animated show just to
begin with so there's all these other
mediums that we think it could also
exist on that are very interesting and
for us it's always about exploring what
that long-form narrative is be it in the
web series format or this season for a
more TV show like format or in terms of
like you know give animation or comic
the other mediums yeah we're not we're
not against anything I think I think for
these three seasons an arc like the
actors you know they're they're growing
up and they're gonna do their stuff so I
think we've kind of this is a very like
close thing but the world in the IP is
rich and we can do other stuff with this
yeah I guess we never know we might do
small spin-offs we might just somebody
else may work on innovative comics it's
something that we can do to play clients
I'd like to grab utilize and you yeah I
mean I think I think we'll enjoy these
threes this three season arc and then we
probably won't do a whole another one
like this way we'll see where it goes
and for us too we don't want to be stuck
doing just one web series over and over
again that's like the only thing we have
even this year we have a slave of you
know three or four other web series
ideas that we want to be pursuing
because it's we don't want to be like
okay they use the guys that make music
guys we don't need these guys to make a
whole bunch of us yeah we're all gonna
be easier because we knew the characters
but we have to essentially learn how to
write it movie format into nine parts
which exactly just made us right in my
opinion it made me write a good
structured movie because instead of
doing three axis like we have to make
sure there's something interesting
happening every 10 minutes attendant is
this really what all movies should
actually be and we have this essentially
go into TV format whether it's different
especially the characters we have got to
get used to writing three stories per
episode you know Brian and Ted now
there's a plus B Block C plots in every
single offices so just like those were a
most seasoned TV and it's kind of tough
to keep track of the story there's some
TV writers somewhere who's like has a
snifter of brandy laughing yeah even
though there's only 45 minutes longer it
feels like we were doing six vGHS is
okay they're each contained like all the
stories there's six whole episodes
yeah I feel like entire movies but a lot
more fun like we get it right
you know DK is anymore and we always new
characters and it's just great
season what's I'm happy with the
recognition that we get is you know it's
really what we get from our families you
know we have we have ten thousand two
before the Kickstarter in very
significant ways and it's like for us as
a creator we have that vouched for by
the audience and they're letting us sort
of play and make this world and do what
we want to anyway a fulcrum we have
freedom from that like that's as far as
I need you know like if you don't really
need anything more than that especially
as someone who gets it's like we wake up
we get to make whatever we want and it's
something that we made at the way like
we have a lot of fun doing it's like you
shouldn't be asking for any more yeah
very happy they're not so young and the
streams are so young and the amount of
content out there are so diverse and
difficult to find that's hard to be
considered snuff because there's so much
content the fact that sex is not
nominate for anything means that the
people who are running these award shows
are not watching anything because sex
house was far and away the greatest
thing that's amazing I mean anything
that gets recognized industry cuz
there's so difficult to find good
content yeah this it's this is Nasr
there's an award show at this point yeah
it's nice to be able to voice cuz
there's so much content out there now so
it's nice to be loved fine Steph yeah
seriously sex out so you guys are you
guys seeing that